he had it he still couldn't believe that
he had it very few professional thieves
managed to steal something so valuable
right from under the nose of the scp
foundation and even fewer lived to tell
anyone about it kasden gripped the bag
in one hand holding onto it so tightly
his knuckles felt like they might split
he was drenched in nervous sweat the
claminess of his palms leaving an
imprint on the material of the duffel
bag its precious contents moved around
loosely every time it jostled and
knocked against him kasden had to fight
the urge to unzip the bag just to remind
himself this was all actually happening
but he resisted he knew the mask wanted
not only to be seen but to be heard as
well the earpiece his client had
provided was doing its job keeping the
whispers at bay dampening the telepathic
aura enough to ensure that kasdan
retained control over his own faculties
the bag he'd been told would also
hopefully dampen the powers of the
mask's corrosive fluid he'd been prepped
extensively for this job more than any
other in his long and storied criminal
career it had taken months of planning
staking up the home of a foundation
researcher stealing his access card and
slipping into the heavily guarded
facility undetected as if that hadn't
been hard enough he then had to find the
right containment cell containing what
he'd been hired to steal just like any
heist the timing was everything he had
to make sure he was there on the exact
day the glass container housing his
target was due to be replaced thanks to
corrosion damage having been gradually
melted and worn away over time at an
intensely precise moment on precisely
the right day kasden had to enter the
cell and sedate not only the research
staff that had come to swap out the
glass container but the armed guards
posted outside too
then it was just a case of slipping on
the specialized gloves he'd been issued
grabbing the mask and stashing it in the
bag with protective lining to stop it
from being corroded during transit all
things considered casting had been doing
pretty well given the circumstances that
was until he heard the blare of alarms
ringing out his heart which had already
been drumming away in his chest through
sheer nerves now began beating so fast
it threatened to crack his ribs panic
shot through his entire system and at
that moment all sense of rationality was
dropped faster than a lead balloon any
further attempts at subterfuge were
pointless why keep hiding
surely the alarms were for him cast in
thought and immediately started running
losing all cover he barged past a pair
of foundation researchers and lab coats
knocking them both to the ground a storm
of paper files they'd been carrying were
hurled up into the air a temporary smoke
screen to cover kasden's panicked escape
one foot launching past the other he
barreled down the facility's corridors
the same way he'd come in if he was
quick he might make it before they
sealed the exits and trapped him inside
the chances were slim and kazdan knew it
but he was left with no other choice
apart from letting the scp foundation
catch him hauling him off to god knows
where for interrogation he barreled past
moore foundation's staff some of them
holding their hands out to try and stop
him as they figured out what the alarms
were for and why kasden was running
shoving one out of the way he felt
something snag at the lab coat he'd worn
as a disguise one of the researchers had
him kicking a leg back casting clipped
the man's knee and whipped himself free
of the coat not letting him stop from
running he was close now so close to the
door he'd come in through if he could
just pass this corner he'd be home free
the clomp of multiple heavy steel-toed
tactical boots came rushing through the
entrance to meet him a squad of men one
of the foundation's infamous mobile task
forces were hurtling towards cast in
like a tidal wave wearing all black
combat gear he skidded as he tried to
turn back the way he'd come stumbling
over his feet as he was chased by the
sound of angry shouts commanding him to
freeze drop the bag and get on the
ground cast and dared not look over his
shoulder catching hints of the oncoming
mtf agents in his peripheral vision
compelling him to keep running but with
no idea where to go and four heavily
armed operatives clipping at his heels
there was little hope of escaping now a
powerful weighty force struck kazdin's
back knocking the air out of his lungs
as it pushed him over and kept him
pinned to the floor he could barely move
as the agent tackled him gasping as he
desperately tried to pull his breath
back the rest of the squad gathered
around him all yelling and warning him
not to move but there was another sound
no
another voice drowning out the soldiers
the earpiece the one thing keeping his
mind safe it was gone it must have
fallen out when he hit the ground and
now the mask could get in the whispering
was unintelligible nonsense really
caston couldn't clearly make out what it
was saying he only knew it had quickly
become the only thing he could hear and
how it made him feel he had to put the
mask on it was such a strong compulsion
it felt like so much more than a want a
desire to wear it it was a need the bag
was so close dropped to the floor where
he had been tackled if he could just
reach it and tear the zipper open he'd
have the mask in his hands rolling over
kasden lashed out at the mtf operative
catching him by surprise as his fist
connected with the man's balaclava
covered face the agent was stunned
lifting some of his weight that had been
pinning the thief down just enough for
casting to free his other hand another
pair of agents tried to hold his
flailing arms to the ground only for him
to reach up and pull one of them face
first into the concrete floor with a
bloody crunch with every ounce of
strength he could muster kasdan moved
like a man possessed hurling the agent
on his other arm into the first who had
tackled him slipping out from underneath
the crumpled agents he crawled on his
stomach as far and as fast as he could
casting desperately scrambled for the
duffel bag it was so close a mere few
inches away his fingertips brushing up
against it as he reached but he couldn't
grab it as much as he felt that
overwhelming need to his feet were still
buried under the weight of the mtf
operators and their gear stopping him
from reaching any further until one of
the agents moved just enough to free
casting's foot everything seemed to move
in slow motion the mtf soldiers were
reaching out to pull caston off the
floor as his hands shot forward and
tightly gripped the straps of his bag he
could feel hands wrapped in tactical
gloves gripping at his shirt in that
same instant he wrenched the bag towards
him and pulled down the zipper he had to
get what was inside even if it killed
him he barely noticed his earpiece
getting crunched under the heavy combat
boot of one of the agents instead he was
inhaling fumes from the interior of the
bag its specialized inner lining already
melting thanks to the viscous black
substance secreting from the mask kasden
didn't even register the pain in his
hands when he reached inside the
secretion corroding his bare skin as he
retrieved what he'd been hired to steal
what he so now desperately needed to put
on his face
scp-035 the possessive mask time felt
like it had ground to a halt freezing
everyone kazdin stared for a split
second at the white porcelain surface of
the mask it felt like it was glaring
hatefully at him thanks to its
exaggerated tragedy grimace it was
almost as if it disapproved of casting
as if he was somehow unworthy of it but
holding it in his hands the compulsion
to put on
scp-035 was now so unbearable oblivious
to the foundation agents around him who
were trying in vain to restrain him
again casting tipped his face into the
mask and everything went black it was
like being half asleep his awareness of
certain things stripped away things like
the pain searing his face a gradual
acidic burning that was eating away at
his flesh corroding his body and yet
casting could still feel occasional
sensations tremors running up his arms
as his fists made contact with something
then pulled back and struck again
leaving behind something wet on his
knuckles but he couldn't see all around
him was shrouded in darkness he knew his
body was moving maybe even walking
taking him somewhere but he had no clue
where and no control anymore it was like
someone something else had pushed his
mind out of the driver's seat and now
had both its corruptive hands on the
wheel his mind was now lost in the
blackness shut down
gone
it was only when he came back around
that casting felt the sheer unrelenting
agony fully wash over him the mask was
off again leaving him a scorched
screaming mess he was laying on the
floor of another containment cell this
one was different from the one he'd
stolen as cp-035 from it was less
heavily guarded minimal security it
might not even have been in the same
facility casting had no idea how long
he'd been wearing the mask for all he
knew apart from the intense pain of the
corrosive black sludge breaking his body
down and the blood stains on his hands
and clothes was that he wasn't alone
someone else was there with him kazdin
didn't know the strangest part of all
this he should be dead no he was dead
much like dr bright's medallion the
possessive mask typically wipes the
human mind like oxiclean if he was back
it meant somebody brought him back
somebody with truly great power craning
his head up he caught sight of the
cell's only other occupant even
squinting through his stinging eyes
casting couldn't make out exactly where
the other man was from only that he was
much older he was looking down a cast
and writhing on the floor there was
something almost
sad lingering in his eyes there was a
kind sympathy behind them not just from
looking at someone with such severe
injuries but an almost apologetic gaze
like he was sorry that the pain even
existed in the first place glad to see
you back my son
the old man said it's been a while since
i've needed to pull someone back from
that deep in the darkness
i was worried i'd be a little rusty
the old man gently reached a hand out
towards him and took caston's pain away
he didn't heal him not fully just hit
pause on his wounds but before he could
thank the kind stranger the mask started
whispering again only this time it was
calling to the old man no longer hurting
but still reeling from what scp-035 had
done to him casting tried to stop the
man
calling with a rasping voice begging him
not to listen to the possessive mask's
call he didn't seem as spellbound as
casting had been in fact the old man
almost just looked like he was going
through the motions pacing over to where
scp-035 lay on the cell floor picking it
up and just like kasdan had done he
lifted the porcelain mask over his
wrinkled wisen face helpless unable to
do anything other than watch on in
horror kazdin couldn't help but notice
the tragic frown carved onto the surface
of scp-035 had shifted now it was a wide
gaping smile a comedic grin with nothing
but ill intent behind it while he had no
idea who the old man was some swirling
sickening feeling in the pit of cast in
stomach told him nothing good could come
from putting that twisted mask over
another anomalous being if he had only
known that
scp-343 was colloquially nicknamed god
by the foundation's staff and was widely
believed to be the sole creator of the
entire universe then kasdan would have
used all his strength to pull the mask
off of the old man's face and smash it
to pieces but it was already too late
the very second the possessive mask
slipped over
scp-343's face the ground shook
violently like the very earth itself was
afraid of what had just happened still
watching from the cell floor kasden
looked at this combined creature it
stood still for a moment slowly
breathing through the mask before it
lifted its hands and appeared to examine
them the comedy smile on scp-035 made it
seem like the mask itself was looking
with a warp sense of glee at its new
host body more of that same black goo
was being secreted out from beneath the
mask drops of it were rolling off the
old man's shoulders they landed on the
cell floor melting tiny burning holes as
the substance dripped down through the
concrete and steel of the facility his
body being puppeteered by the mask on
his face the old man wiped a smear of
the sludge away with his hand looking at
it in his fingers it wasn't melting him
the same way it had to caston usually
the corrosive secretion that scp-035
naturally produced proved to be its
weakness melting the bodies of its human
hosts and eventually destroying them
leaving the mask without a form to pilot
scp-343 on the other hand was only
humanoid in shape and far beyond any
mortal being that the possessive mask
had ever enthralled the combined being
corruptive mask and omnipotent god
raised its hands high like a conductor
before an orchestra from the spot he lay
in casden watched in horror as every
member of staff in the facility was
pulled up through the floor or dragged
screaming through the walls piping and
brickwork tearing through them this was
a minimum security foundation wing far
more relaxed with only a handful of
staff and a light force of guards still
to
scp-035 it didn't matter how many there
were it was enough to make a start the
wrinkly hands of its new hosts clenched
sharply the foundation staff all
suspended in midair suddenly exploded
each one of them every researcher and
guard erupted into a fireball burning
white hot like heated metal before
fizzling out there was nothing left no
scraps of clothing no remains they just
weren't if it wanted to
scp-035 would have thrown its head back
and laughed maniacally in some strange
way casting thought that might have been
better instead it was silent the mask's
wide soulless grin conveying its twisted
delight well enough it turned to face
the wall thick layers of concrete
standing between it and the outside
world and began stepping forward so
completely casually that it was
unnerving with its first step the walls
of the cell surrounding the scp-035 and
scp-343 hybrid as well as casting began
to crumble away with the second the
corridor outside did the same falling
apart without any exertion of effort
from the masked god each and every step
further more of the building around them
was chipped away carving a path through
rooms and research stations towards the
edge of the site it was as though the
concrete and brickwork the dense heavy
materials that constructed the facility
suddenly had the consistency of wet sand
and scp-035 and its new host were the
tides coming in washing away all in
their path no longer in pain but his
body distorted beyond repair casting
forced himself up off the ground at last
weekly he limped after the creature
thinking in vain he had any chance to
stand against a being with the unbridled
power of a god and the infinite cruelty
and malice of the possessive mask if he
could just get close enough casting
thought he could tear the mask away
freeing the old man he wouldn't be able
to stop himself from putting it on a
second time but perhaps it was better
that kasdan wore it and let its black
ooze melt him down at least the wise
kindly old man would be able to get far
enough away from
scp-035's influence and kazdin could at
least in part but this right after all
he'd stolen the mask from the foundation
this all started with him as the hybrid
reached the farthest wall the barrier
turned to glass and shattered the
combined monster looked out over the
waiting helpless world the rest cp 343
the possessive mask had control over
chaos and creation alike and nothing on
earth that could challenge it not the
foundation not humanity not even other
anomalies lifting its still lifeless
grinning mask upwards the sky darkened
the deafening boom of thunder ringing
out above forked bolts of deep orange
lightning cracked across the atmosphere
as what was left of the foundation
facility dissolved behind the masked god
though it was facing out towards a world
that would soon crumble as easily as
this building the creature could see
everything far beyond where it stood the
lives of billions upon billions all at
once it watched plants grow while others
wilted animals born only to die humans
living out their ritualistic existences
each one of them gradually heading for
the same fate and through all of that it
saw a hand trembling behind it reaching
for its mask caston he was so close
fingertips just about to brush the
porcelain surface of scp-035
when suddenly the mask and the old man
wearing it were gone casting turned
around in confusion only to find it was
now standing behind him it reached out
one of the wrinkled bony old hands and
touched a single finger on his forehead
caston blinked and he was back back
before the heist before any of the
wonton devastation had begun he
recognized the room he was in and sat in
the very same place where his mysterious
benefactor had approached him with a
seemingly impossible job to steal a mask
from the scp foundation sure enough
sitting across the table obscured by
shadow was the client but behind his
eyes casting was trapped helpless as he
watched himself live out the same events
that had led to the mask being placed on
the face of god he couldn't change the
course of history couldn't avert the
apocalypse that was already happening
all he could do was watch his heart
sinking as his client pushed a file
across the table opening it to reveal a
photograph of his target the thing he
wanted cast and to steal
scp-035 the possessive mask and
meanwhile back in the new hell of its
own creation the mask was having some
real fun
now go and check out
possessive mask and scp-343 god to learn
even more about this pair of anomalies
and pray that nobody ever has the chance
to combine them